never have i ever
been truthful and revealed my body count
to my partner
this question confuses me have you ever
lied about how many people you have been
with
no i'm sorry have you told have you all
have you
told the truth
in actuality
to how many people you've been you told
them the truth
okay i don't think i've ever been asked
i just drank have i ever have i ever
told the truth
yes and i got a drink if i've ever
revealed there it is wait rule of the
number
four you drank first and you drank
quickly brody what happened when you
revealed your
body count
i hate that word i don't like it either
but you use it with sexual partners
body account you use when you count dead
people i'm just saying
i like it
you're right i'm wrong
i use
to me is the thrash band with ice tea in
it that's that's better yeah
anyway so it's a phrase maybe it's not
exactly
the most endearing however you've told a
guy how many partners you've been with
yeah we're all human so we're all we all
have these you know
needs and once and uh i've always been
honest any time the topic comes up which
i always kind of hope it doesn't with
one partner an israeli guy that i dated
for a while it turned into like a
two-week long argument oh god what
happened why
because he just kept asking more and
more questions was the number high
that's why he wanted to know
was it someone that you slept with do
you want to know more about that
specific one
what are you willing to say like they
don't know
like i again like i don't love talking
about uh body counts but i think it was
because i was in a time in my life where
and this is a little painful to talk
about but like a lot of women experience
this where they have they're navigating
sexuality
and they end up having a bad experience
and then
they jump back into that world and
they're not really
taking care of themselves and in some
cases i think it's even self-harm so for
me like
i would say there was a time in my life
where my body count was getting a little
bit higher than i than i necessarily
needed it to be
um so
he kept prying and prying and it just
wasn't something i wanted to discuss you
know
so when you said you weren't taking care
of yourself how do you mean i think
physically emotionally mentally what do
you mean well i think when you when you
share your body with another person
it takes a huge toll uh whether that's
i mean a toll is not usually negative
but like it it has an effect on you
whether negative or positive so i think
a lot of women um
experiment with sexuality and it becomes
kind of uh like a like a self-soothing
kind of thing even though it harms them
like you know how people cut themselves
because it feels good in the moment even
though it's harming themselves no so sex
is like cutting yourself so i think
she's saying it like sex in the wrong
circumstances with the wrong people in
the wrong headspace
yeah absolutely go ahead
uh nothing i was just going to say like
in excess i think is what she's trying
to say people like sex addiction or
whatever but amongst women yeah it's to
comfort yourself are you always truthful
with the guy you're with if he asks you
i would hope that no man asks me i think
it's adorable if a guy did i say how
many boyfriends have you been like if
you she posed the question in a
tactful manner no you lie in that
instance you would there's no good
number to give them none
am i right or am i wrong they're because
what because
yeah they think you're lying they always
think you're lying they're gonna think
it's five times as much as you say
because a lot of it is sex i've never
heard of that before
that's my answer
no
no diamond no what say that hold on i've
never heard that what was that no hymen
no diamond explain that tori fnf gang
city boys we up
what does that mean
from them no it's like no i'm in no
diamond it's something that they say
overseas virginity virginity you're
going to give you're not going to give
it up until you have a ring
um
anyway rolo your thoughts on this body
count uh disaster situation
one of the lesser known uh iron rules of
tomasi is never willingly reveal your
body as a guy
never willingly reveal your body count
because
it will be used against you at some
point
for the most part it's if a woman's
asking you that you're in a different
kind of you're playing a different game
then then you're negotiating at that
point rather than than uh
then having this the chemical reaction i
would say as i was saying before not
cool
but also you have to remember that it's
an opera it is an opportunity so when
when somebody like when a woman asks you
like how many how many girls have you
been with right that's a [ __ ] test is
what that is
it's it's what do you mean that's a [ __ ]
test it's it's a test of uh
are we playing the game and do you know
that we are playing the game how many
how many girls have you ever been with
and if you say if you give an actual
number yeah that's like that's almost
like the rich guy telling you he's rich
right that's like i'm alpha so here's
here's what i've been with you know 100
girls what times if they ask you is it
more than ten well
is it more than twenty yeah i ask if i
feel girls have asked that it's an
opportunity it's an opportunity to ask
if you feel inadequate yeah why would
you ask if you feel inadequate well
absolutely
yeah i inadequate how explain that like
inexperienced like i want to know how
many hoes i have to keep up with
what is that even mean
what do you mean what does it mean i'm
like if you spend with more than 20
women yes there's no way that i will
perform like
uh
better than them there's more people to
compare me to it's more of an insecurity
thing than it is anything else you're
saying the more women a guy has been
with yeah the more cars he's driven the
more experience he has he's going to
compare you
to all the girls he's been with
and that's it i actually disagree with
you i should disagree with social
anxiety but i'm going to help you out
with a question i'm going to help you
out here because
no one's gonna it's all about the
connection with the person 100
it's not about the actual
sexual activity i got over that belief
okay i'm just saying i've certainly
asked it before and if it was
well actually it really wasn't that long
ago that was probably why i ghosted a
guy over it because his number was too
high yeah it scared me really what
happens if a number is too low would
that scare you i
i only asked because this guy had a blue
check mark really well known like high
value man i was like a musician
it was like he's probably slept with a
lot of women well just just so we're
enthusiastic what do you want to see
what's uh what do you consider a lot of
women
more than ten more than fifty more than
a hundred we just talked about what's
the system yeah number is like i mean it
was like over he was like i don't know
maybe a hundred so that's a high number
to me if you're gonna say anything like
20 is fine for me i wouldn't be worried
about that okay i don't know that's it
can i give your audience your male
audience some advice yes please this is
why you're here if your girlfriend is
asking you what your body count is it's
most likely that she just needs
reassurance that you are into her and
you like her body
so the answer you need to give her is i
don't even remember anyone before you
mm-hmm and that's it you're welcome i
love you you're actually my first
women i've slept with tonight you know
like you use that as a as a point of
humor or something
to refresh
i love
why would i even remember that number
when i'm here with you
boom and you're out okay all right
segway before you agree and amplify you
go oh yeah i don't know twelve thousand
something like that yeah you just agree
with me on youtube
that do that
fourteen hundred lays
yeah the fat kid and that embarrassing
it's a good embarrassing
[Music]
you